alexis bonjour bonjour heureux de vous
retrouver ce matin sur rtl france alors
on lisait les nuits d'émeutes se
succèdent en guadeloupe le gie gène a
été envoyée en renfort avec avec des
équipes du raid est ce que cela va
changer quelque chose
alors je ne sais pas si ça va changer
quelque chose parce que ça fait des mois
que les syndicats les habitants de l'île
essaye de se faire entendre par les
pouvoirs publics par la métropole par ce
gouvernement qui choisit le
pourrissement la division c'est toujours
à peu près la même chose et donc les
émeutes ont été laissés finalement
chaque nuit
libre cours parce que les l'idée c'est
de discréditer les mouvements sociaux
les syndicats derrière qui demandent des
services publics de qualité qui demande
simplement être entendus et qui luttent
bien sûr contre ces lois de confinement
ces lois de vaccination quasi
obligatoire et qui demandent un débat
donc envoyé le gign ça va peut-être
calmer les émeutiers la nuit ça ne
calmera pas je crois la colère sociale
dans l'île et la volonté aussi d'être
entendu le problème c'est de faire
l'amalgamé entre d'un côté les violents
les émeutiers ceux qui font des pillages
et de l'autre côté les syndicats ceux
qui tiennent des barrages ceux qui
veulent aussi se faire entendre parce
que sans sa personne au gouvernement ne
prendrait en compte la voix des
habitants de la guadeloupe et guadeloupe
et et métropole une relation se met deux
heures
oui c'est pas nouveau à l'émeute la
façon de se faire entendre pour ce
territoire d'outre-mer
1967 émeutes suite à un acte raciste il
ya eu sept disparus 7 morts on a attendu
longtemps avant de savoir il reste
encore beaucoup de zones d'ombré puis
2007 c'était michèle alliot marie qui
était alors ministre avec yves jégo qui
ne savaient pas quoi faire non plus là
encore émeutes pour se faire entendre
contre la vie chère déjà à l'époque et
puis aujourd'hui la guadeloupe c'est
quoi ces des services publics en
lambeaux c'est 20% de chômage voire plus
chez les jeunes de 20% d'illettrisme de
l'aude non potable où il faut récupérer
de l'eau de pluie même dans les hôpitaux
on demande même à certains qui viennent
se faire opérer d'amener l'euro avec eux
voilà la situation du nil qui demande à
être traité comme l'est le citoyen
lambda en métropole or on voit bien que
ce n'est pas le cas et d'où je crois
cette tension permanente avec la
métropole et on voit bien qu est ce qui
s'est passé le gouvernement en août
envoie 300 soignants pour les antilles
qu'il fallait répartir entre les
différents territoires est là et bien
très vite on envoie le gign 200
gendarmes de plus pour avoir un total de
2250 pacificateur on pourra les appeler
comme ça qui sont sur l'île pour enlever
les barrages mais il n'y a pas de
dialogue social même si jean castex va
recevoir quelques représentants de l'île
on voit bien cette stratégie du
pourrissement elle est systématique
c'est ce que veut emmanuel macron et ce
n'est pas comme ça qu'on va résoudre les
problèmes fondamentaux qui sont en
guadeloupe
alexis avec ce dernier épisode est ce
que c'est une course en avant des
pouvoirs publics qui pourrait coûter
cher
we say say say say stratégie de
l'affrontement permanent tinqueux choisi
emmanuel macron on se rappelle bien sûr
la violence qui a été déversé sur les
manifestants d'aidé gilet jaune on
continue ici simplement en guadeloupe
avec ses stratégie du diviser pour mieux
régner du pourrissement également en
laissant les mouvements sociaux chercher
à se faire entendre et puis en le
renvoyant la troupe plutôt que en
demandant à se mettre autour d'une table
c'est la même chose seulement la
guadeloupe est là cette histoire de deux
rapports difficiles avec la métropole
les uns de se faire entendre avec les
émeutes et puis il y à aussi dans les
territoires d'outre-mer à bientôt le
référendum en nouvelle calédonie qui
pourrait du coup changer totalement le
vote un dd des nouveau nés des quais des
calédoniens par rapport à l'indépendance
et puis il ya ce ras-le-bol je crois
qu'à un moment on ne peut pas d'un côté
c'est le en même temps ma cronista faire
croire que on est là pour les coudes
qu'on voudrait un nouveau mandat 50 plus
pour cinq ans d' écoute et en face
envoyez le gign et les gendarmes pour
taper sur des gens qui demandent
simplement des services publics de
qualité donc l'annoncé quelque chose qui
ne peut pas passer dans les territoires
de thomas mais également en métropole
quand on voit la façon qu'a le pouvoir
de gérer les crises sociales merci
beaucoup alexis c'était
l'édito politique de
alexis poulin a retrouvé sur les réseaux
sociaux fois